yeah the launch of this empowered girls
hockey program couldn't have come at a
better time here at the arena as Spirits
were high take a listen
well yes it is
two-time U.S Olympic women's hockey
player Megan Keller sharing her love of
the game with girls here in the valley
nice good job made possible through
Bauer hockey and the Vegas golden
knights the empowered girls hockey
program is an eight-week session for
girls ages 5 to 12 years old think of it
as an all-inclusive Guide to the sport
they're getting outfitted with
everything sticks skates bags jerseys
Bowers providing twenty thousand dollars
of equipment for girls in Nevada to try
hockeys this program led by all female
coaches kicked off Sunday with 30 girls
ready to take on the ice some with ease
While others still getting adjusted to
the rink Megan who won Gold in 2018 and
silver just last year shares how vital a
program like this is to our female youth
I wasn't really exposed to girls in
hockey until I was in Middle School and
I saw the Olympics on TV for the first
time and it comes around every four
years and that's when I realized girls
play hockey and that was something I
wanted to do so we're Bauer and the
golden knights are doing is super
important to be able to grow the game
and Inspire the Next Generation and
parents like Amanda jerusulis agree
she's pleased to have her daughter
Kailyn be a part of it she fell in love
with hockey as soon as we started going
to the golden knights games it's a great
start as a mom like it's nice to see
that they have a program that's meant
for girls
[Applause]
again today was the launch of the
program as it will continue until August
now if successful the hope is to
continue it next summer reporting here
in Henderson Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now
according to USA Hockey the amount of
women participating in the sport has
grown by 681 percent here in Nevada
since the golden knights joined the NHL
six years ago